good evening members it's seven o'clock
can we begin please thank you right good
evening and welcome to this evening's
short transportation meeting on the 12th
of October 2022.
um the fire procedure if the fire alarm
is activated please forgate the offices
via the stairs obviously the lifts in
the foyer please do not use the lifts
assembly in holy Square on the green and
offers will assist you and advise when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
could everyone present please ensure
that mobile phones are switched to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive calls in a chamber whilst this
median is in progress
filming of meetings I would advise that
a filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas they have
their image captured I urge anyone
filling procedures to avoid Fielding
members of the public particularly with
our children present does anyone
intending to film the meeting
I think not
[Applause]
does any member wish to speak under 20.1
no thank you right agenda item one is
apologies for absence we have apologies
from Council Binks are there any other
apologies
please
ask have we got a KCC uh highways
officer here tonight I will I will tell
you about that very soon thank you very
much thank you all right are there
gender item 2 is Declaration of Interest
are there any Declarations of Interest
hello thank you
a general item three is the minutes of
the previous meeting do members agree
that the minutes of the joint
Transportation board meeting held on the
9th of June 2022 the approved and signed
as a correct record
can I have a proposer please
Council scoby seconder Council Crow
thank you for Coburn so thank you very
much
all right agenda item four
can I just set up on my point of
Interest
Paul valak and Richard heaps KCC
counters have informed us they will not
be attending this meeting tonight Casey
says KCC insists on a digital attendance
however TDC currently does not have
their facilities to allow for hybrid
meeting
so that is your answer Council dogs
all right so right agenda item four is
parking and waiting review for various
locations across than it
and I've got the lovely lady beside me
Abigail who will go through that with
you
chair thank you so this is a report and
a proposal for some introductions of new
parking and waiting restrictions across
the area of thanet
um I will go through these and if anyone
has any points they wish to raise whilst
I'm going through please feel free so
we've got a proposal for an extension to
existing double yellow lines in Hibernia
Street in Ramsgate this is just to allow
access to the drive of number two when
trying to exit to the right due to cars
parking in the lay-by they're not able
to pull out fully so we are just
extending slightly to allow clear access
when exiting to the right
we have top Hill Street in Minster in
Ramsgate we are proposing to install new
WL lines to assist with access issues
for emergency services and larger waste
recycling vehicles and that is opposite
54-52 top Hill Street
please bear with me sorry I'm just
scrolling through
we have got ayton Road in Ramsgate we're
proposing new W lines on a tight band
outside number 16. this is due to access
issues for Waste and Recycling vehicles
and it is resulting in loss of
collections so that's just to improve
the flow of traffic
we've also got a proposal for WL lines
opposite the junction of St George's
Road in broadstairs this is due to
Vehicles parking on the highway sorry
the footway opposite the junction
resulting in pedestrians having to enter
the road so we're going to put double
yellow lines there to prevent that
we've got Harold Road in Margate we are
extending the existing double yellow
lines across the driveway of 56 in line
with other residents in the area due to
parking across the driveway
Herbert Place Margate we are going to
introduce the addition of residential
addresses in Herbert Place numbers 8 to
11 to be added to our Margate West
permit Zone these addresses were
previously part of the High Street but
due to conversions and separation of the
shop and the flats they have now got an
address of their access on Herbert place
so they would have been entitled to a
residence parking pervert under the High
Street so we're just adding these
addresses so that they will still be
entitled to purchase a residence parking
permit within the area
we will also be proposing Corner
protection W lines on Glebe Road and
Glebe Gardens in Garland Margate
and we will be looking to introduce new
W lines in Old Boundary Road Westgate
down the entire length of the road to
approve traffic flow for residents
and that's the end of my my report thank
you
thank you Abigail
um do they must have any questions or
comments on the report please
Council cows acquitted thank you chair
um with regard to title Street Minster
now I checked with our all of those
development plan this morning we've got
no knowledge of this at all so I don't
know who's put in for that but we have
got some outstanding lines that we're
going to put in a place called the
corner of Norton drive and the High
Street
which we've had requests from from local
residents for sort of posters when I was
spoke to our visit now
as I said but we've got no recollection
at all with any any request for yellow
lines between 54 and 52 top little
street so if we could have a bit of
clarification from that at some point
yeah yeah thank you councilor that that
request actually came to us from a
member of the public so it came directly
to us in the parking office yeah and
we've carried outside visits as a result
of that and that's why we've and we've
that's why we're bringing it to you for
approval yep
Council chalk
enforcement's okay if it's enforced how
many enforcement officers have we got
because
I do travel on the bus quite a lot I
know I don't show my age and using my
bus pass but the buses have a hell of a
job to get around because of people
parking on yellow lines I see a van in
Ramsgate parked on yellow lines all day
so we can have as many yellow lines as
you want but if nobody enforces it that
is a bigger biggest problem at the
moment thank you
thank you okay
thank you councilor Shunk so in regards
to that we have just done a recent
Recruitment and we have uh successfully
I'm going through the recruitment
process for two new civil Enforcement
Officers so we are short staffed at the
moment but we are working hard to
enforce and increase our enforcement
team and if you have got any specifics
feel free to speak to me after because
we are working and extending our hotspot
areas and we are trying to work with
public and counselors to find out those
areas that are particularly issues so
that we can try and be more present in
them areas during our shift patterns
any other members Council comfort
thank you Chad
um with the old Boundary Road double
yellow lines down both sides
is there likely to be any review of the
parking charges in that St melters car
park because residents are already
struggling to park anywhere near their
homes mostly due to the permitted
development at the Waterside site
so I was just wondering the parking
charges are quite excessive and the car
park is
empty rather than full most of the year
thank you
thank councilor at the moment there is
no plans to review the charges they are
only seasonal charges so they are only
on charge between April to October and
they're in line with some of our more uh
sort of lower cost car parks for a
24-hour stay but at this moment we're
not looking to review the charges there
um The Proposal was a request from
residents in the era for double yellow
lines however
will say well if the board would like to
make any suggestions moving forward
thank you Council counselor Lewis okay
um I think this is relevant
um the limes car park
the barriers have been broken or not
working on a regular basis now for over
a year the loss of revenue must be
colossal because people are parking in
in droves there without being charged
has anybody looked at that situation
regarding possibly returning to pay and
display
thank you Council today
thank you
um we are aware even though the barriers
have been vandalized around in working
order the car park is still fully
chargeable and it is still
um a pay as you use car park we are
looking at options at car park and we
are looking either
um doing a sort of plan for the area to
see how we can improve it moving forward
to make it more beneficial but
unfortunately I haven't got any more
information on that at this time because
it is very early days of us looking into
it and my director who unfortunately
couldn't be here due to
um arranged annual leave due to the
reschedule of the appointment might have
had been able to offer you a bit more of
an in-depth answer there but that's I'm
afraid we are looking into it but we
haven't decided on the Avenue we're
going to go down as of yet
so given that answer could we have an
update at the next JTB thank you
thank you Council thanks a lot thank you
any any other
Council heart
thank you
um just as a comment I bought this up
before I think
um the multi-story that we can all Park
in around the back
you still haven't got a height
restriction notice on that
so and I have brought that up before
other meetings and I think it's about
time I actually put a hype restriction
on there if I'm wrong I'm happy to be
corrected but I still I went in there
that day and I don't use it very often
but there's still no height restriction
marking
thank you
thank you Council Hart
cancer talks
I must ask these questions while I'm
here and I was trying to represent
Ramsgate uh
in the summer months and even now you've
got a legal parking along the harbor
building wetherspoons high performance
cars it's quite a clearly a sign says
you're only allowed to park there if
you're fishing these cars are not
fishing it's a there's lots of Revenue
it's all well on that Hardware
uh goes on daily everywhere you've got
two type of car parts there you've got
the one that's Outside The Maritime
Museum which is chargeable
you've got the normal charging along the
road this Harbor arm they just go along
there at quite a speed and these cars
are not fishing they're just parking
freely
I just wondering whether you can have a
look at that sometime thank you
thank you um can I just clarify sir are
you talking about the Ramsgate Harbor
arm because you off where I'm saying
yeah
um I will come back to you and with an
update on that because that is managed
by different departments so I can look
into that
thank you Council thank you Abigail any
other members
okay the recommendation is subject to
the views of the board the the shown
Independence one are approved and the
proposals which require statutory
consultation and the proposal and as are
advertised and that any traffic related
objections are reported back to a future
meeting of the board
it's north down Road Margate
um I haven't got a KCC Council officer
here so do members have any questions or
comments on the report please
um thank you how do I formally complain
that the director of Highways and
transportation is refusing to meet this
committee
thanks
any membership which we wish to have a
question
obviously will be taking your questions
and they will go to the officer
who is
at KCC I bring it up continuously I
can't see any problem why they can't
turn up I know this happened concerned I
don't name his name he's a good chat
when we can get hold of him so I used to
bring it up all the time and at the
moment I'm just hitting the brick wall
doesn't help me I've got a whole lot of
issues I can't deal with and we're KCC
unfortunately I it's nothing I can do
about it I'm very sorry about that this
is a situation where we've got at the
moment uh it's all stem from covid we
are all back here as you can see my the
officers can't be here I don't
understand
David Hall thank you um we have uh
local offices here can they tell us when
you can actually do a hybrid meeting so
maybe they could actually attend uh is
it possible will it happen can it happen
every live streaming from members of the
public and that is the reason we cannot
do both
so the one time where we did have a high
bridge
we had a virtual meeting for cases the
officers we couldn't have the live
stream streaming for members of the
public and so we're in a very difficult
situation again because members of
public like to be
on the live stream so that is the issue
thank you
so
um I I do understand the reasoning with
the hybrid and the live streaming would
it be possible for this committee to
suggest to TDC that they upgrade upgrade
their system so that it could be hard we
could have live streaming and hybrid
that would stop that would solve the
problem
I'm sure they have thought about that
but I will go over to to my offices
beside me here and ask him if there is
that or
you're going to maybe have a solution
all right
thank you I this is something that we
can bring forward to Nick to put
together some kind of
um some initial thoughts as to the costs
involved in in upgrading our system but
from the initial discussions that we had
it looks like there is some substantial
amounts of money that will be involved
in putting together an upgrade for the
system and most of that I think the
council had already
funded the upgrades that we currently
that we are currently using so uh we can
still take it back to Nick and possibly
to uh um the CMT to see whether there is
a way forward but in the meantime I
suppose uh the board can through the
chair this chair or the substantive
chair
um engage
uh the cabinet member for transport from
KCC to see if they can
agree to getting us back to the
arrangements we used to have prior to
covered Arrangements uh because we we
used to meet in person and we used to
get support from KCC officers so this is
something I think that would need some
kind of a push from the board through
the chair
has actually spoken with KCC to to the
member officer who's losing Whoever has
portfolio this is and allegedly he
wasn't very helpful at one stage but I
have been told allegedly that they can
come if they wish and I don't know if
any other cases I can give you more
information because I've asked that
question directly to the cabinet member
I
and his answer was negative to say the
least he said
he he didn't want to
um he didn't want to instruct the
officers to come to the meeting so this
negativity and the blame lies entirely
with the cabinet member for highways at
KCC it's not anything to do with the
individuals who
could come but they've been instructed
as far as I know not to come
so you are saying you're actually told
him they shouldn't come that's what his
reply in the public it's their choice
well that was our they can't come it's
just they don't want to come no well I'm
only quoting what was said in public at
the council meeting that I asked the
question I'm sure the other
um members from the KCC remember me
asking that question and it was
negativity what happened after that
question I I can't I'm not privy to but
the and I can only say what was said in
public to me when I asked a direct
question
is thank you Council Lewis I've just got
to say that Council um Bings who is the
chairman actually did speak with a
company member who told her that they
could come if they so wish but obviously
you'll
say can I just say KCC
all need commitment that's it here
deserve to be listened to and the
residents so I do feel that it's
absolutely appalling that we've got a
Cabinet member of my party
that isn't well he's not in the with the
real world it's appalling it always got
questions and answers but because we
haven't got nobody here I mean I could
get up I didn't storm off last time then
I just made a point I've been at
maystone all day can't get home have a
cup tea and come out like all of us to
try to get some of these issues resolved
and we just we're just hitting the brick
wall so
thank you Council Sean's counts
councilman
I think I think um I understand what
Charles is saying that we should try and
talk to the cabinet it isn't going to
work
the cabinet member as the others have
said has stuck his he was in and
um
he's not got the appetite to let the
officers come out so but he all the time
he comes back to our inefficient
I.T systems you'd be quite happy to let
them let them take part in a hybrid
that's what that's why that's why I've
suggested that we formally try and do
something about it
okay thank you Council the thing is we
haven't you know why why can't they come
we're all here sitting here today
I can understand why at covid we aren't
all sitting with moss either so you know
it's it's this is a joint transportation
meeting and they should be here unless
there's a really good reason
so we're all very upset and annoyed
about it
but we don't appear to be able to do
anything about it
as Charles has told us you know it's
very costly to upgrade they've already
it's already been upgraded in order that
we can get as far as we can go but for
the live stream Etc
but you know where do we go from here
yeah a couple of the reasons given was
the distance traveled and some attended
planning meetings and got abuse but in
terms of our officer he lives three
miles up the road that was exactly going
to say that but he does he doesn't live
very far so there's no that's no excuse
I've got cancer
and can I just think that maybe we um
take a collective decision not to
progress any decision on any KCC
um motion or or item on the agenda if no
one wants to come in and talk to us
about it
okay we can't make a decision if you
want to defer if we all feel that we
really do need this these members
officers here we can defer the media in
fact you know there are lots of
questions that need to be answered and
even if we have a virtual meeting you
cannot really get your answers over as
when you've got face to face here so if
if members are agreeable
we will defer these two next two items
or gender item five and gender items six
are both
the KCC
so are there any members that obviously
don't agree with that
I got reservations because
um for example I've got a 20 mile an
hour speed limit
um consultation that's been passed and
has to just come for
um ratification at the next meeting
possibly so it
I'm a bit wary of going down this path
because things that the residents want
on is aren't going to be able to carry
on because we've deferred it
indefinitely until we get a new Cabinet
member basically so I'm a bit hesitant
um that's what I meant but I'm a bit
wary going down that because the public
will suffer
um thanks sorry just just uh just to add
my my thoughts and concerns so it's more
of a comment but at the last meeting we
made recommendations to look at 20 mile
an hour if you look at this report in
front of us it says the scheme was
endorsed by thanic joint Transport Board
in June makes no reference to our
recommendations and further down in the
consultation actually causes discussions
of 20 mile an hour noise in quotes
so I feel like we're being disrespected
in the report as well as having their
officer here tonight
Where Do We Stand we've got obviously
counselors who wants to carry on
um
I didn't say that I just said I'd
reservations sorry can we
can we defer the meeting then with
reservations because it's
I quite don't quite know what to do with
myself personally we've had instruction
from
I think we just make a composions to
defer the items until the next meeting
and as simple as that and then again if
we have to we'll defer them again
it's not difficult I mean if KCC wished
to pay for
um a hybrid meeting then and pay for our
um way to do it if they can't then maybe
they have to send their offices it's
their Shout at the end of that it's the
ball's in there cool
um and I mean you know we all know who
the who the cabinet member is
um and he really just needs to sort this
out and if he doesn't want to then maybe
he needs we need to talk to um the chair
of Kent County Council the leader and go
from that way and go above his head
okay thank you councilor Hart so we
would
can I can I just say I'm I'm watching
Abigail and she's kind of like the pawn
in the middle of all this this is ABS
can I just make it clear that this is
not not it's no reflection on your work
and I know you've put a lot of work in
and I think could we admit that that
which suggests that we have already
actually been through the parking that
has already been yeah yeah have a
proposal in a second or so we haven't
that is not an issue for Abigail that's
all been done yeah I'd just like to make
sure
because she's the case she's looking
very lost there and wondering what she's
going to say with say tomorrow
um but but
it's not it's no reflection on yourself
can I can I make a proposal
please if you would thank you uh so uh
item four on the gen15 says members are
asked to note the contents of the report
and the consultation Report with a
recommendation to proceed with the
proposed measures I'd like to make a
proposal that we don't make that
recommendation without being able to
question the KCC officers we've done a
gender item four we're on our agenda
item five and six
number four honor again
agenda we have done that we've had we
have had to propose on the second one
that one on on January and forth for
parking
five now gender item five is now what
we've got to do five and six we've got
to do
haven't we sorry
we've done item four parking
four sorry okay can I have a second for
that please
thank you Kansas goby
thank you members
can I speak on the motion because I
speak on the motion please
um
when we made this decision
can we forward that decision to the Kent
County Council Cabinet member and leader
of the council and given the reasons why
absolutely so if that is agreed as a
dementia the members all agree I'm sure
you all do yeah thank you
all right so that concludes the business
for this evening
thank you for your attendance this